we welcome the republican nominee
president trump
and the democratic nominee vice
president biden
i beat bernie sanders not very much i
beat him a whole hell of a lot i'm here
i'm here standing facing you hunters
would have left two days early you would
have lost every price oh he knows how to
do super tuesday you got to look very
long there's a deal
i got very luck gaming very lucky
tonight as well and tonight i'm going to
make sure
because here's the deal here's the deal
the fact
is that everything he's saying so far is
simply a lie i'm not here to call out
his lies everybody knows he's a liar but
you i just want him
to tell you that i i i i want to make
sure you did last in your class
can you let him finish sir no he doesn't
know how to do that he has
you know christ you picked it'd be a
surprise the wrong night at the wrong
time listen you agreed with her
there sanders no manifesto number please
let him speak mystery number two he just
lost the left
number two i i you just lost the left
you agreed with bernie sanders on a plan
absolutely
i'm not going to answer the question
because because the question is
the question is radical left will
a lot of people died and a lot more
going to die unless he gets a lot
smarter a lot quicker mr president did
you use the word smart
uh so you said you went to delaware
state but you forgot the name of your
college
you didn't go to delaware state you
graduated
either the lowest or almost the lowest
in your class don't ever use the word
smart with me
don't ever use that word oh give me your
because you know what there's nothing
smart about you joe 47 years you've done
this let's add this to ben
you would have had let me just tell you
something jeff if you would have had
the charge of what i was put through i
had to close
the greatest economy in the history of
our country and by the way now it's
being built again
let's get to the economy in the next
segment sir okay oh mr president
i'm asking you a question will you tell
us how much
you paid in federal income taxes in 2016
and 2017. millions of dollars
you paid millions of dollars millions of
dollars millions of dollars and you'll
get to see it
he says he's smart because he can take
advantage of the tax
code and he does take advantage of the
tax code that's why
i'm going to eliminate the trump tax
cuts but why didn't you do it over 20 in
the last 25 years
because you weren't president because
you weren't president screwing things up
you were a senator you're the worst
president that america has ever had
let me just tell you joe i've done more
in in 47 months i've done more than
you've done in 47 years joe
will you urge your supporters to stay
calm
during this extended period not to
engage in
any civil unrest and will you pledge
tonight that you will not declare
victory
until the election has been
independently certified
president trump thank you very much for
joining my supporters to go into the
polls
and watch very carefully because that's
what has to happen
i am urging them to do it as you know
today there was a big problem in
philadelphia they went in to watch they
were
called poll watchers a very safe very
nice thing they were thrown out they
weren't allowed to watch
you know why because bad things happen
in philadelphia bad things
and i am urging i am margin my people i
hope it's going to be a fair election if
it's a fair election
i am a hundred percent on board but if i
see tens of thousands of ballots being
manipulated
i can't go along with that and i'll tell
you what from a common sense does that
mean you're going to tell your other
people
it means you have a fraudulent election
you're sending out 80 million ballots
they're not equipped these people aren't
equipped to handle it
number one number two they cheat they
cheat
hey they found ballots in a waste paper
basket
three days ago and they all had the name
military ballots they were military
they all had the name trump on them vice
versa i think that's good
vice president biden final question for
you will you urge your supporters to
stay calm
while the vote is counted and will you
pledge not to declare victory until the
election is independently certified
yes and here's the deal we count the
ballots as you pointed out
some of these ballots in some states
can't even be opened until
election day and if there's thousands of
ballots going to take time to do it and
by the way
our military they've been voting by
ballots
first since at the end of the civil war
enough in effect and that's
and that's what's happened going to
happen why was it not why is it for them
somehow not fraudulent it's the same
process
it's honest no one has established at
all
that there is fraud related to male
imbalance are you willing tonight to
condemn
white supremacists and militia groups
and
to say that they need to stand down and
not
add to the violence in a number of these
cities as we saw in kenosha
and as we've seen in portland
i would say almost everything i see is
from the left wing
not from the right what are you what are
you what are you saying i'm willing to
do anything i want to see peace
sir say it do it say it do you want to
call him
what do you want to call them give me
your name give me a white supremacist
yes you'd like me to conduct
this and write problems stand back and
stand by
but i'll tell you what i'll tell you
what somebody's got to do something
about antifa and the left because this
is not a right right-wing problem
this is a left-handed direction this is
a left-wing
white supremacist antifa is an idea not
an organization you've got it
that's what his tonight fbi his fbi
director
says well thank you and good night
thank you
uh
[Applause]
you